Margo Jaffe nineteen eighty nineteen
eighty-one 1985 College of Dental
Medicine I arrived here when I was 21
years old for graduate school I was very
young and in my class we had 12 women
out of a class of about 60 before then
there were one two three students that
were women almost no women faculty so we
were sort of like trailblazers was hard
to find mentors we had to get very
mentally tough and perform very well
academically and clinically and I think
the person that had the most influence
is the current senior associate dean dr
martin davis who was a phenomenal
teacher educator writer and a motivator
when i was a student here i was a
recipient of financial aid it made it a
lot easier for me that i did not have
that debt load when i finished here and
I feel it's very important to give back
I took both postgraduate pediatric
dental students I taught them
orthodontics and sedation I taught
undergraduate pediatric dentistry and I
still continued 30 years later to have a
lot of students come through my office
and I always say after a day of spending
a day in my office they know if they
want to be a pediatric dentist and
orthodontist or they want to run away
from children
well I never really left the university
I think there's only one year I wasn't
present at this school in some capacity
being president of the Alumni I really
never saw myself speaking in front of a
group I always was a little
uncomfortable but I sort of found my
voice after three years receiving the
Alumni metal was one of the best
experiences I ever had in my
professional career the reason that I
did all these activities and I was so
involved in school as I love the school
and I felt it was my responsibility and
duty to give back but it really did feel
good to get an award and to be
recognized for it